- [Reporter] Each trading
day at 11:00 a.m.,
the Chicago Mercantile Exchange, or CME,
host 10 minutes of
electronic trading of these,
blocks of wholesale America-
made cheddar cheese.
Like some other food products,
the last couple of
years of cheddar trading
have seen some wild sessions.
For example, here's a drop
that analysts attribute
to the first coronavirus lockdowns,
when schools and
restaurants started closing
and halting purchases.
But during these swings on the CME,
the price of cheese here,
at the supermarket, held pretty stable.
In fact, if you chart it out,
the price consumers pay for
cheese has stayed more steady
than some other common foods.
Here's the chains for ground
beef and eggs and apples,
and here's cheese.
There has been some inflation,
but the swings you see on
the CME are largely absent.
With the price of many
foods on the rise right now,
we wanted to better understand why,
even with the choppy wholesale prices,
has the price of much of the cheese we buy
at the store stayed pretty stable?
The wild swings in wholesale
cheese prices play out
on the CME's auction platform.
Traders buy and sell those 40-pound blocks
and 500-pound barrels of cheddar.
The blocks are sliced and shredded
and sold to grocery stores,
restaurants, and others.
And the barrels are primarily turned
into processed cheese products.
These are the only cheese
traded on commodity markets
and cheese sellers all over
the country watch the prices,
especially of the blocks.
- Okay, so I make Swiss cheese.
There's no stock market for Swiss cheese,
there's no futures
market for Swiss cheese,
but can I use the insight
I got on cheddar pricing
to say something about
what Swiss is worth?
- [Reporter] To better
understand the wholesale swings,
we spoke to Andrew Novakovic,
an agricultural economist
who's been studying these
markets for over 40 years.
- If I think, for example,
Swiss should always be
worth more than cheddar,
at least a little bit, if
the price of cheddar goes up,
well, maybe the price of Swiss
that I charge should go up.
- [Reporter] So when the
price of cheddar swings
like it did in 2020,
so does the wholesale
price of other cheeses.
Again, here's where bulk orders
dried up early last year.
And around here,
the government started
the Farmers to Family
food box program to help
farmers weather the storm.
It included a promise to
buy a $100 million a month
in dairy products, including cheese.
- Thank you. Have a good day.
- There were several
different types of baskets
that they authorized.
There was a dairy basket
and a milk basket.
And they paid to acquire those products,
put them in a paper
bag or a cardboard box,
give them to local food
distribution centers.
We saw the price of
cheese absolutely explode
for a short period of time
because there was this requirement
to get this huge volume of
cheese in a very narrow window.
- [Reporter] After a few months of shocks,
prices returned to a bit
lower than what they were
right before the pandemic.
As these programs ran their course,
influencing more sharp swings,
customers were picking up vast quantities
of cheese at stores,
which brings us to the question at hand.
Why on average are these
swings hard to notice
in the dairy aisle?
Novakovic attributes it in part
to something called price smoothing.
- When prices are increasing
rapidly for some reason,
grocery stores tend to say
we don't want to reflect all of that.
They anticipate being
able to recoup that margin
at some point when prices recede.
So instead of seeing quite
the same rollercoaster
at the retail level,
generally consumers see
a much smoother effect.
- [Reporter] Novakavic says
says customer expectations
can also influence pricing strategies.
Take apples.
Because they're grown seasonally,
customers may expect
them to go up and down
throughout the year more
than something like cheese.
Also cheese is perishable.
Customers may buy it more
frequently than other foods
and would be more likely
to notice price changes,
another incentive for groceries
to keep prices stable.
While some in the cheese business
have had to weather big market swings,
a smaller section of
the industry has managed
to bypass much of the storm.
Eran Wajswol, who owns
an artisanal creamery,
told us that while the
CME was swinging in 2020,
his business was thriving.
- 2020 was one of our best years
because of farm markets and direct sales.
The public do not want
to go to retail stores.
- [Reporter] Producing their own milk
and selling direct to
consumers allows some artisans
to skip the wild wholesale markets.
- We are basically a farmstead creamery,
which means we make most
of our own milk onsite.
We age our cheeses in a cave
onsite and we're original.
- Wajs said that while he's protected
from some market conditions,
2021 has still presented challenges.
- '21 is rough because of labor.
We're producing and
selling everything we make,
but a few of us are working longer hours
to make the same stuff
because we can't find
enough people to make it.
- Wajs said that while
he's managed to hold steady
on prices so far,
he's feeling this year's
supply chain pressures
like much of the rest of the economy.
- The way we are doing it is
sometime increasing the minimum
that the customer has to buy from us,
changing delivery minimum,
increasing delivery prices,
trying to hold...
I don't know how long we can hold on.
If it continues the way it's continuing,
it's gonna have to get a boost,
but we don't like to increase prices,
and we haven't probably in
cheese for almost five years.
- [Reporter] As the economy
continues to see supply
and production challenges,
the price of cheese on commodity markets
and in the store remains uncertain.
(quiet pensive music)